except to say expect the unexpected
[Music]
because of the past eight years has
shown us anything
[Music]
is that this universe is far bigger than
any of us could have dared imagined
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my arrow season eight
episode ten series finale video that's
right this is the end everyone press f
in the chat to pay respects to the show
and to Stephen Amell they ended with a
really big teaser so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos there's a bunch of big
stuff coming up especially the Green
Lantern HBO show that's gonna be
happening in the next couple of years
I'll explain that at the end of the
video to a lot of the Easter eggs and
setups we're in service of a lot of the
new TV shows that they're gonna be doing
inside the DC TV universe premiere Lee
Superman the Green Lantern showed the
green arrow spin-off show so I'll try to
explain that as we go through Easter
eggs careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet will do top 10
WTF and Easter eggs as we go along so
starting with number 10 welcome to earth
prime
Deathstroke so they do a bunch of
different flashbacks during the episode
the first one opens with Starling city
and 2014 during the events when
Deathstroke was killing all of his
mother during arrow season 2 but we find
out that it's actually a flashback to
Earth Prime's history in 2014 during
these same events and this time Oliver
used a pocket knife to free himself and
save his mother it's brand new footage -
they shot it in the finale with Manu
Bennett coming back to film the new
scene so this is actually brand new
stuff made to look like it's old number
9 they do a new version of the Emerald
Archer documentary they did that I think
it was last season where they basically
had a documentary titled the Emerald
Archer that was also the name of the
episode you find out though that in
present-day Morda Queen Oliver's mother
knows that she died in the previous
timeline they know about an alternate
reality they knew that their version of
Oliver sacrificed himself became the
spectre and won't be coming back anytime
soon
it gets really meta when all the
characters start to understand the
complexities of the multiverse like wait
a minute there was a monitor and an anti
monitor an antimatter wave wiped us all
out through most of the early parts of
the episode they also show flashbacks
especially during the documentary - the
other big crossovers in previous seasons
just referencing the events of his life
for the most part everything went down
similarly it's just that in this version
of Earth primes reality Oliver brought
back a couple people that died in
previous timelines you also slowly find
out about the other people that Oliver
brought back to life in the new timeline
when they get to the end of the episode
in the funeral so I'll talk about that
in a second there were only a couple
people that they didn't bring back and
explain why in a second they tried to
provide some logic for it during the
episode and I feel like it's mostly
solid number eight WTF everyone comes
back to the arrow cave and drinks
Oliver's vodka to toast his memory this
is the vodka that he kept stashed ever
since season one is stuff that he had
brought back from him with Russia when
he was in the Bratva but they sort of
used this scene to reference what all
the other main characters are gonna be
doing next Renee is gonna become mayor
Dinah is gonna become the new police
chief
Lila accepted a promotion in Metropolis
so Diggle is moving their family to
Metropolis with her also I think because
Diggle is gonna cameo on the Superman TV
show if he's not gonna be a main
character he'll probably just guest star
every once in a while also because of
what happens to him at the end of the
episode - but number 7 WTF all the arrow
season 1 flashbacks so obviously there's
a billion different things you could
flashback to in the series finale but
the most impactful would probably be
represent stuff from the very first
episode in the very first season but the
first big one is him going back to the
raft watching his father kill himself is
basically them showing you the moments
that provide the logic for why Oliver
did the things he did like why didn't
Oliver bring Robert Queen back to life
with everyone else well as they
speculate during the episode is because
Oliver couldn't change things that would
fundamentally change his own timeline
preventing him from becoming the hero
that he became in an order for that to
happen he needed to watch his father die
on that raft they also used these early
season 1 flashbacks to talk about how
the mission will never be over and in
the flashbacks Oliver's talking about
the list there's too many names the
mission will never be over so they're
just trying to connect that to the list
this way they spent so much time at the
end of crisis on Infinite Earths with
that scene setting up the idea of the
new version of the Justice League or the
Superfriends however you want to refer
to them but number 6 Sara goes to the
future in Star City 2040 to pick up Mia
because that's basically where her show
is gonna take place if you didn't watch
arrow season 8 episode 9 last week they
basically didn't explain her for what
that spin-off TV show is gonna be it's
gonna take place in the future both
Canaries will be showing up on that but
there'll be time displace so it'll be
these Canaries from present-day
time traveling into the future and then
being on that show if you're also
confused about why the Queen mansion
still exists is because of the earth
prime changes in the timelines way back
between season 2 and season 3 there was
a tie-in comic book where they basically
burnt the mansion down so when you
started in season 3 there was no more
Queen mansion getting really meta I
think the reason why the writers
rebooted or brought back the Queen
mansion in the earth prime timeline is
because they wanted to use that on the
spin-off TV show in order to explain why
it could exist in the future they had to
say that it didn't get destroyed in the
past but number five WTF
Oliver versus John burned in the
flashbacks so really big easter egg but
remember we're connecting this to season
1 moments and Oliver when he was still
really stabby
going through the list Diggle tries to
talk some sense into him but he's
getting ready to go take down this human
trafficker John Byrne the name John
Byrne sounds familiar because he's
actually a famous comic book creator he
created a bunch of x-men characters like
Kitty Pryde Emma Frost Omega Red
the Scott Lang ant-man John Byrne is
also the name of a villain in Mark
Guggenheim's final episode of Law &
Order that he wrote so he's put a lot of
law and order Easter eggs a lot of Billy
Joel Easter eggs into arrow episodes in
the past they have a couple moments with
Mia at the computer banks and present
day acting like felicity like they just
want to tie a link make her seem like
she's a lot like her parents she's like
Oliver in that she's becoming the new
version of the green arrow in the future
but she also kind of looks like Felicity
and she works computers like Felicity
the number 4 WTF was the big team-up
that they all have in present-day to
save the young version of William who
gets abducted by John Byrne after he
gets out of iron Heights prison they
kind of used this as a sort of rally
moment a reason for them to all come
back together why do you think I called
everyone because they had to canvass the
whole city so it also provides you with
a couple of different vignettes and
scenes of the characters talking about
each other talking about where they've
been the last couple of years they even
brought back Ragman there been so many
of you on my videos that have asked what
happened to Ragman how come he never
came back he was so Opie his ability was
so powerful he actually explains that it
just quote-unquote took a while for his
rags to heal to regain their magical
properties and he has been acting as a
vigilante on his own ever since there's
a very notable wayne easter egg talking
about batman stuff i don't think it
means the Batman's gonna show up inside
the arrowverse any time soon but you do
have the bat woman TV show and because
they're doing a superman TV show there
will inevitably be more Batman Easter
eggs within the DC TV universe they also
sort of use this Williams save as a call
to action for Mia because she wasn't
able to say William in the future the
older version of William but I think
arguably the bigger moment is
when Roy proposes to Thea like they kind
of make you wonder what's gonna happen
with those characters in the future you
also notice if you haven't been watching
arrow that Roy also lost one of his arms
and has the cybernetic one just like
comic book Roy Harper if you were
confused about the title of the episode
to fade out is actually a term for a
part of the bow itself the name of the
hero the name of the show is arrow so
obviously there's a ton of bow and arrow
references throughout the history of the
show as well as in the title of the
episodes but fade out also a reference
to the show itself in the characters
fading out like this is the fade out of
the series because it's the serious
finale so number three WTF Thea and Roy
are getting engaged they also referenced
their first meeting back during season 1
him stealing her purse and how her and
Oliver's mother used to hate him a lot
more in the old timeline you have to
remember the weird thing about this new
version of all the characters is that
they remember that there used to be
another version of reality they haven't
said when Thea and Roy are gonna pop up
on any of the other TV shows anytime
soon but I'm assuming every once in a
while one of them or the other will
cameoed either during a crossover or
during a big episode of one of the other
series there's a big moment with black
siren being guilty about earth one
Laurel being one of the characters that
was not brought back like why was she
not brought back was it because I'm here
Quentin tries to make her feel better
because he is one of the people that was
brought back and he knows that he died
in the previous timeline they turned
down the lights in the air okay for the
last time bit of a sad moment you
remember though that it's left in pretty
good condition and it still exists in
the future of Star City 2040 during
Mia's timeline but then they had a big
candlelight vigil unveiling the arrow
statue Quentin references a lot of the
events of season 1 and season 2 when he
was going after all of her night and day
I used to hate Oliver I blamed him for
the death of Sarah on the Queen's Gambit
and how he regrets so much of that now
because of the hero that Oliver was able
to become the statue reads he saved this
city there were even some fans in real
life that wanted to get the CW to try
and leave the statue up permanently in
Vancouver where they filmed the show but
Marc Guggenheim explained that when they
constructed this for the show
it wasn't constructed to stand forever
so it would basically just be torn apart
by the regular Vancouver weather so it's
not meant to last that long so if you
ever wonder why there is no permanent
Green Arrow statue that's why number 2
WTF they have Oliver's funeral and
there's a whole bunch more cameos a
bunch more people come back that weren't
in the earlier
- the episode thean moira reference why
Oliver probably couldn't bring Robert
Queen back but Tommy is back talking to
black siren he references being married
to earth one Laurel and how weird it is
about how cool it is that she's there
both Talia and Nyssa al Ghul come back
they joke about their relationship as
sisters they reference their terrible
father
Rachele Ghul and they joke about Nyssa
getting married - Oliver sorry about the
death of your husband Oh you know I had
that an old a long time ago and then up
walks Sara and Nyssa introduces Sara
to Talia as her beloved still I can't
remember the last time that Nyssa and
Sara were in a scene together
Felicity meets adult Mia for the first
time because Emily BETT Rickards mostly
sat out this season of arrow like she
didn't want to come back down for season
seven but of course she's gonna come
back for the series finale we also see
that Barry comes back because obviously
very very important character to all of
his life to offer his condolences to
Felicity and everyone else and everyone
jokes that they don't know what to say
in a moment like this but Diggle is
probably the best person to say
something because he was there at the
beginning in that pilot he was the first
person to team up with Oliver they
became brothers in his eulogy is sort of
a twist on the arrow intro narration
that Oliver always has I have to become
something else
but deagle says that something else was
to become a better man they do that big
montage about where all the characters
are heading next like I said Diggle and
Lyla headed to Metropolis probably
because Diggle is gonna cross over on
the Superman TV show every once in a
while but the thing everyone is probably
going to be talking about after this
episode you know number one big WTF they
pay off the long-running fan Theory the
Diggle would eventually become the Jon
Stewart of the arrow verse as he's
getting ready to pack up and drive off
there's a spacecraft that crash lands
right next to him and he grabs a ring
box opens it up green light from a Green
Lantern Corps ring shines on him the
spaceship even looks a little bit like
Abin SURS spaceship from the Green
Lantern movie and really met a deep cut
Easter Egg for the original Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern movie Marc
Guggenheim longtime arrow showrunner in
Greg Berlanti himself also were involved
with the making of the Green Lantern
movie so that's also one of the reasons
why they included that Green Lantern
movie footage during crisis on Infinite
Earths implying the Green Lantern's
existed within the arrowverse but also
early speculation I think it's going to
be Diggle
in Lantern crossing over with Superman
four episodes of his TV show when it
starts later this year like I mentioned
earlier there is the HBO Max Green
Lantern TV show but I don't know when
that's going to premiere and I don't
know if Diggle is gonna go on that too
I'm assuming he might cameo but I think
for the most part he's at least going to
show up on the Superman TV show they
also pay off that final scene of
felicity going with the monitor at the
end of season 7 we never really found
out what happened to her or where she
went we find out that it was her going
into the afterlife to be with Oliver
there is no returning from here and it's
actually a recreation of a moment that
they had during arrow season 1 inside
his mother's office they're both wearing
their clothes from season 1 when they
first met but she's confused she's like
wait a minute we met for the first time
down in the IT department and he's like
no no no it's more complicated than that
and you see the scene of the flashback
that they did in a later season where he
actually saw her at an earlier point in
the timeline it's just that she didn't
remember meeting him until the IT
department during an arrow season 1
episode the timeline gets a little
tricky but let me know if there's any
big Easter eggs that you spotted in the
episode that I didn't mention in the
video and let me know what you think
about Diggle becoming the Jon Stewart
Green Lantern of the arrow verse I'll
probably do another Green Lantern video
sometime tomorrow just talking more
about what's going on with the Green
Lantern TV series the Superman TV series
and Green Lantern's in general on the
arrowverse TV shows in future crossovers
everyone click here for all my crisis on
Infinite Earths videos and to watch Ezra
Miller crossover with Grant Gustin one
of the best scenes from the crossovers
and click here for the boys season 2
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay awesome you have saved
this city
[Music]